do you think women marry a lifestyle yes
what do you guys think yes oh yeah I
think smart women do I think they do but
it doesn't lifestyle doesn't mean have
to be doing up holidays it can be I just
want to be married with kids and I just
want to stay home and I don't want to be
working all the time or I want to get
pregnant that's also lifestyle so yeah
they definitely married for a change
they want to change whatever life
they're living I think potential plays a
huge part in it her
uh her ability to see the potential on a
man will determine what kind of
Lifestyle you have um
what percent of American football
players get divorced do you think
as well slowly I feel like maybe their
women stay but I was watching a program
on the NFL lot and a lot of them have
like homegrown women like homegrown
women
childhood sweetheart type yeah right
yeah so I had maybe a lesser percent
like maybe some like 70. but they also
got like
injuries and stuff like that so it's
it's um yeah and they're really volatile
and yeah yeah I mean yeah that's techy
I'll give it a Civic yeah same I'd say
about 75. you guys are good 60 to 80
that's what they argue
you know billionaires have the lowest
rates of divorce and highest rates of
marriages maybe because they have the
most to lose but it's also like
billionaires just don't get
divorcedure yeah they take off he makes
another 100 billion later on and they've
got the highest rate of marriage they're
like 87 of billionaires are married and
they've got the lowest rate of divorce
well I think it's because
um
they stay married for a legacy where
where
um people that like get money quick
often lose it quick and they usually
also come from Rich families and so they
grew up in for a parent like that kind
of Lifestyle whereas people who get rich
through Sports and music they don't
usually come from stable homes always
well I just think of like the gates like
Bill Gates Hillary Clinton or um
um Hillary like sorry not the gate sorry
the clintons the gates got divorced the
clintons how they stayed married even
through everything but I don't even
think they like each other exactly
that's like a legacy thing yeah yeah
well what do you see respect and
everything you know reputation talking
about all of these factors Legacy what
do you what do you guys think about like
um Nick Cannon
because you can't invest in each child
equally when they're from sporadic homes
financially but you can't emotionally be
available yeah but even if you had one
household with
um 12 kids yeah have you seen cheaper
about a dozen no but it sounds bad news
there's kids going missing you know I
mean at least I would say this right if
you if you divided the kids up amongst
different households yeah they would get
more attention from their mother at
least a good point when you think about
it because I was one in ten we didn't
see my dad a ton he was gone a lot yeah
I know but you know there's the
knowledge of that he's going to come
home whereas with when you're sporadic
it's like Dad might not come here
you might say listen every Sunday we're
gonna round everybody up and we're gonna
you know yeah
yeah because in all of history it's been
multiple women it's that like 8 000
years ago 17 men reproduced for every
one man it's not like the men were like
the kids were fine but they would all be
in one home and when you have separate
homes you also open up the doors for
other men entering the home with your
children and child abuse increase are
you sure yeah 100 child abuse is higher
I wasn't talking about that part I was
part that they were there because like
in the old days like men had to go off
for months no as in they would all be in
one home he'd have to provide for one
home one household it wouldn't be for
ten different women in 10 different
Villages that one just doesn't that one
just doesn't benefit the women
that you know nikana's ideology just
doesn't really it doesn't benefit the
children because you're opening them up
to step parents
me if I if I woke up yeah one day and I
realized that I got a brother I didn't
know about and did it and I got this
whole big family in a four hours the
only child I'm not going to be upset I'm
not gonna lie or if your mom had entered
a stepfather who was abusive to you
throughout your life
what are you talking about when you when
you have lots of like 10 different baby
mums you're opening the door up for step
parenting step parenting is linked to
more of child abuse and home neglect
even if not abuse neglect because they
start a new family and the child always
feels like an outside looking in so
that's on the women though I don't even
think that's on the man that's seven
that's 17 irresponsible woman that's one
irresponsible man yeah if anything I
think that shows that women would rather
share a successful the guy than have
than keep a guy that they actually would
be faithful to them I think guys are
going to start doing that when they
reach a certain plateau of success it's
they said that Tate has like I just saw
something online like that he has like
10 kids if you believe that I'm not
surprised he hasn't denied kids he says
I wouldn't come on here and say I had
kids but he doesn't actually say he
doesn't have kids or maybe you know his
smart mind is probably keeping them out
the lighting yeah yeah
yeah would you want lots of different
mothers for your children
I would like you know if I wanted a big
family then I wouldn't be against it I
don't necessarily want a huge huge fan
because I've got a lot of brothers and
sisters anyways seven seven kids to one
woman now that's a lot man am I even
gonna want that pumpkin
I'm not joking about this
would you ideally like one baby mother
or several ideally
uh one wife or maybe a mother of a child
like you and your children would you
like them to come from one moment and I
said like if for three yeah I think
three is manageable in one home oh
you'll have a headache freeze management
so three in one home and then like two
and then if I wanted ten then I'd split
them I would I would speak to them and
be open and say all right cool let's
let's give you a rest
but yeah that's his rotation
yeah what would you guys do
I know but I wouldn't like I well like I
like my
um my my grandfather he has loads of
kids like 15 kids and stuff so
um I've me personally part of the reason
I got mad I didn't really want to do all
that I wanted to have kids when I was
married I didn't want all this just like
kids everywhere or whatever
um I just think negative because
ultimately like when the fathers removed
there's this problems so I've always
wanted to to be married and have kids
within marriage and it's just better for
the kids in general so that's my party
no I agree with that too yeah it's
interesting because I see both sides
because like on one hand that was so
common in all of history
you know what's interesting that the men
can't marry multiple like I don't know
here can they legally marry more than
one person no that's a Christian country
but it's interesting because they could
still be baby mamas so it's like they
might as well get the legal benefits I
don't really like I wouldn't go that
route so it doesn't affect me but it's
just interesting how One is paid One is
paid and one kid
I mean they get paid you know CSA how
does that work if you've got loads of
kids low different families it's a
certain amount split up between I just
know in the UK you you get a cert you
get I don't know if they still do it but
at one point you got free housing if you
had a kid and you're incentivized like
if there's you get more either money
from the government or child support if
you have multiple dads who are actually
incentive yeah they actually like pay
you to have multiple baby mothers
she comes on the shadow if you guys have
seen her but she even said that like
people would want to move out of their
parents house so they would have a kid
back in her day yeah and they again they
would give them a flat and stuff if they
got back up
I mean you've got to do like about a
couple weeks at the YMCA but after that
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and
Ties on
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible